met face-to-face before halfway thank
you for joining us on the cable show
talk to me about what's happened over
the last few days this week so this week
we've also been in New York trying to
lobby for a NASA needs case I met with
the Foreign Secretary was again talking
about what he was going to be doing I'm
not amazed not first my met him yeah not
the first my met him and he's been great
behind closed doors but he said listen
she wouldn't be in New York campaigning
and I'll be there anyway let's meet
before I meet the Iranian Foreign
Minister and just talk through what kind
of things you want and then I'll be
clear and so we had that meeting on
Monday and tell well so he was I mean
great and open and said listen I think I
think this is outrageous that this has
gone on so long I think it makes me
really angry and I think you know I'll
do what I can this is one of one of our
top priorities and it was kind of wanted
to check for me how strong I wanted him
to be and of course you know it's a
delicate a tentative process sometimes
campaigning and in some ways I'm
probably more strident of the family's
ability it's good to check so we talked
through it I said listen I think really
you know you can't be too strong from
where I am and for me for Nazneen the
fact that the foreign secretary is
standing up and making really strong
statements about how she's innocent and
she should be you know released and
really some humanitarian grounds
released on justice grounds you know any
grounds really will work that's been
great that he's been taking that clear
lead so I wanted to give him that
message that please carry on or to say
listen as Nene it's really important for
her sitting in that prison cell that
lots of people care there lots of people
follow their story but that also that
her foreign secretary and her prime
minister are making clear
representations so that's what I wanted
to say and he took it away
how is she yeah I mean on tenterhooks
ready to see what happens this week and
and in some ways I think having both the
foreign secretary and the prime minister
raising case raising it clearly not just
saying the raise in the case but also
you know come on calling for a release
can only give her strength
we've obviously had the pretty rough
time just recently so she was released
for a few days and I was talking to you
know whatever II was so happy with a big
grin on my face just for people who
don't know the details of the case she'd
been in jail for about two and a half
years she was released on a 72-hour
furlough when we talked she called you
she'd woken you up she was in the car
and we thought she was on her way home
I mean I thought probably it might take
a bit of time that we sort of baby steps
but yeah but that's right I thought we'd
cross that bridge and and she's out of
prison and you know she was a big grin
on her face on the first time I seen her
in two years so just lovely to see how
well and happy she was looking at got to
see Gabriella and you know got to show
her show her toys and all the things
that that they've been talking about
doing and finally happened and and so we
had sort of lovely three days that it
was only on that last day that you know
gradually we realized that she wasn't it
wasn't being extended which is what
you'd expect take him back into prison
and that was obviously that sort of on
television she did she did so her
lawyer's advice was was you know I mean
don't go back make them come and get you
and she just didn't want to be have
their security visuals coming in the
middle of the night and the trauma that
would expose Gabriella to so she told
her and obviously Gabriella was very
upset and once she realized how upset
everyone else was and was crying and you
know please mommy stay and but I mean
I'm I think it was right that she she
went in that with a head held high and
but obviously that turmoil of someone's
having that brief taste of freedom and
then it it's snatched back she said she
held herself together until she went
through the prison doors and there and
then just cried for 45 minutes just
inside the gates before she could even
get to back to the cells and then as
became clear she collapsed cover days
was sort of you know numbness and a
nervous reaction and there probably for
the best part of a couple of weeks of
the sort of the nervous tension
expressing yourself and all sorts of
physical numbness not being under walk
properly and strange paints their hands
which which have lingered still so yeah
I think it's that hope turning back and
it feeling like what was that all the
cruel game all alone feels like it
wasn't the mattress made it went we were
disoriented for bits and and wait a bit
quiet in the media and then decide what
we need to come back campaigning and
and that's brought us to New York a
chance to try meet with the Iranian
authorities so I tried to go down to the
Iranian mission to meet with the foreign
minister Zarif had asked to meet with
him didn't manage to but but one thing I
did do was I gave him that you know we
painted some stones to mark the fact
that the Boris Johnson before had
promised to leave no stone unturned to
release nothing we'd give him one of
those stones to Jeremy hummock when he
became farm secretary which he then
showed me he'd kept on his on his desk
as something that you know what's going
to keep keep this case alive I also want
to say listen there are two governments
involved both governments need to take
responsibility both governments need to
protect their citizens she said Nazneen
is British and she's Iranian
I bashed the British governor forcing
listen he should protect her better but
also they've only got moisture
potentially they've signed all these
human rights conventions as well and
they say you need to make them
accountable for it so I gave him a stone
said listen I mean you have a role to
play particularly in terms of building a
good relationship with her on the UK
this is you know this is outrageous and
please find a way to solve it it's not
the Foreign Ministry causing the problem
it's it's the Revolutionary Guard
another part civilian system but but he
has a place to play in the bush and so
we did that we also one of the things we
were doing with campaign we've met lots
of other members of the American
families and Canadian families just
coming together for sort of sharing
experiences it really does because of
course you you know you're all
struggling kind of in silence and you
know the our story is crazy
and then for everyone that listen to you
can't quite believe it's true it's not
unique so actually just to be able to
share and hear the commonalities and the
ways in which pressures were put on the
confusion just you know it's almost a
therapy but but that that chance to sort
of talk through and trust and one of the
things through navigation were this when
talking to the government we're talking
to media even is you don't quite know
what the right thing to do is or you
know what the other agendas are and what
you know the government's think about
other things and major thing you know
that everyone's taking other things so
it was another family know their agenda
my agenda it's the same it's it's you
know they want their loved one out I
want my loved one out and so yesterday
having that chance to just share and
talk through and talk about you know
what it's like to have your your family
member held almost dessert you know
there's a bargaining chip it's not so
that was a really really powerful thing
and I want to ask you this richer I know
it's difficult but it's be interested to
know your thoughts at what stage if at
all did you feel the words from Boris
Johnson cause problems for nothing that
weren't there otherwise when they
suggested just to remind our viewers
that that she was there to train
journalists that's right so the front
secretary said for Monica Johnson said
that in Parliament that mistakenly that
that she was their training journalists
at the time he also criticized her on
and one of the things we've been asking
the government to do was to rid of it so
I was quite pleased thought he's got
that run but but you know at least he's
done look a bit and there was only a
couple of days later where she was
dragged into court and we were a bit but
why she's been brought back into court
and what's what's go and then the
judiciary put out on a statement on the
episode saying it was because of what
the Foreign Secretary said so he's
revealed that she was up to train and
she wasn't she was on holding not but
nothing wrong with training journalists
Jonas brought a job but she was on hold
and that was was always clear and so we
had a whole sort of autumn of spiraling
storage being put in the Iranian pressed
and so on and probably every day it
wasn't quite clear what was happening
and what impact it was and very
stressful and of course stressful for us
stressful for Boris Johnson it there's a
way in which that become a big snowball
of a statement spoke definitely wrong
definitely got it wrong it definitely
took a while to get that acknowledgement
and in that apology it was they're not
quite clear how big a deal it would
become in the end he went to her own and
the case against her which which had
been braised in his name was dropped
it was then raised again subsequently in
this you know there's games that have
been played at different points it was
raised subsequently after and he was no
longer and for so that this there's a
way which it was a really stressful time
and it clearly you know caused grief and
and hassle and and stress and fun as
Nina in particular to sort of that's a
broadcast all these lines being told
them we used his words to justify and at
this point sort of months later I
thinking having a new foreign secretary
they're sort of you know a fresh start
and and a chance to and that's not no
disparagement of a form of architecture
but but it does allow for us to sort of
recalibrate and
and actually what showing me how it's
coming and done in been a lot more
strident without that baggage and say
listen this is this is unacceptable
she's innocent he said that that's
clearly she should be released and she
should never been in prison in the first
place those are really strong statements
that one of the things I said the other
families is no actually you never know
what works what doesn't work but but I'm
so pleased that he said that and he said
that clearly he said nice things
innocent because it's a really important
recognition while you here you've got
another important job in New York as
well haven't you that's right yes so so
I'm I was chatting to Gabriela and and
asked her what her she wants it no she
said wanted to address from from New
York so we're off to Macy's which when
we Nazneen I once came to New York when
Kelly was a little baby and we went to
Macy's for baby baby clothes shopping so
I promise nothing if we come back to New
York we'd go and buy some of the
gabriella room gary was pear-shaped and
she's choosing which color or either a
red dress or a pink one I could go wrong
with a pink one daddy I'm just telling
you know it's good to see it was an
absolute pleasure to meet you in person
and we hope that she's home soon